[Música]
notícias do mundo nos dá hoje estamos
vendo aqui imagens de moradias ruesch
refugiados fome sede seca intolerância
miséria problemas de clima violências
isso daqui é o que a mídia nos mostram
será que isso aqui é real é profundo nos
impacta o dia-a-dia massivamente nós
vamos receber essas imagens externas mas
eu digo mais essas imagens já estão hoje
nos nossos dispositivos celulares
carregamos aqui
isso aqui é uma foto de um vídeo no meu
facebook mostrando um momento de assalto
em copacabana e não só isso aqui eu
tenho uma imagem do nosso grupo debate
zap de amigos dizendo sobre um assalto e
tiroteio que acorreu ocorreu há dois
dias atrás se eu for parar e pensar
nessas negatividades posso esquecer tudo
o que eu tenho pra fazer e lamentar isso
essas imagens disparam em nós um grande
sistema de alarme dentro da amiga dela
não serve nós temos umas dez vezes mais
capacidade de identificar alguma coisa
que vai nos impactar a gente vai tentar
se defender e isso é absolutamente
instintivo é biológico a nossa reação
e algumas dessas coisas que eu vou falar
com vocês agora que são tecnologias
exponenciais elas podem ativar o sistema
de defesa de vocês e o que eu quero
mostrar um pouquinho pra vocês
desativarem um pouco dessas defesas
vamos lá vamos apertar o cinto então uma
pessoa sem dados sem informação e sem
conhecimento é só uma pessoa com um
opinião quando eu nasci em 1971 morriam
128 crianças a cada mil nascimentos em
2013 isso caiu para 13 crianças a cada
mil nascimentos ou seja temos um na
escala de dez vezes menos mortes e em
mortalidade infantil
quando nasce uma expectativa de vida de
59 anos e 2009 já subiu para 72 anos
isso é o que os dados estão dizendo o
conhecimento está disponível hoje 21 por
cento de aumento da expectativa de vida
em 34 anos as pessoas vivendo na linha
abaixo da pobreza e na miséria com 1,90
dólares 111 dólares 90 centavos na época
em 1970 essa esse número é de 2 bilhões
e 100 milhões de pessoas vivendo abaixo
da linha da pobreza
esses números estão caídos já estamos em
900 milhões
nunca tivemos um momento de tanta paz no
mundo tantas guerras ea quantidade de
gente que está morrendo é devido às
violências violência daqui a esse número
aqui pra mim é um dos mais fantásticos
em 1970 56% da população era ela tinha
até era tia literatura não quer dizer
que tinha era alfabetizada esse número
aumentou em 43 anos no meu tempo de vida
aumentou em 51% que isso está me dizendo
que esses dados estão me dizendo que a
única constante que a gente está
experimentando hoje a mudança e essa
mudança tá cada vez mais rápida e as
tecnologias são exponenciais o
desenvolvimento humano ele sempre foi
linear que sempre foi local os nossos
deslocamentos e hoje o nosso
desenvolvimento é global e este
potencial
para vocês terem uma idéia do que é o
linear o exponencial se eu vou dar 30
passos e cada passo seu metro eu vou
andar 30 metros
se eu for andar esses mesmos 30 passos
em escala exponencial eu vou dar um
passo depois dois depois 48 16 32 vôos
dobrando e quando até 30 passes
potenciais eu terei dado 26 voltas em
torno da terra ou seja mais de um bilhão
de passos
eu vou mostrar pra vocês algumas
tecnologias que existem há muito tempo
que conhece impressora 3d pode aumentar
aqui à luz da audiência que eu via já
tem um número que no que ouviu
impressora 3d há cinco anos atrás mas
nós aqui há dez anos atrás ninguém aqui
levantou na impressora 3d existe há 35
anos era uma tecnologia que estava
disponível para os governos e para as
grandes corporações
para vocês terem uma idéia de quanto à
redução tá acontecendo eu vou mostrar
que algumas e mais um hd naquele
distinta no seu computador
em 1956 tinha 5 megabytes precisava de
uma empilhadeira pra ser colocada dentro
do avião e 2005 tamanho chip do tamanho
da porta do meu dedo indicador
com 128 megas custando 99 dólares àquele
hd custa 120 mil dólares em 2014 o mesmo
chip do tamanho do ponta do meu dedo 128
gigabytes
esse é um crescimento de 1.000 vezes em
relação a 1956 é um crescimento de 30
milhões de vezes
isso é exponencial explosão de sensores
esse é esse
esse cara foi o cara que criou a câmera
digital estão vendo aí pesava ser quase
dois quilos tinha 0.01 megapixels de
resolução 10 mil dólares se tirava uma
foto gravar uma fita cassete tirava uma
foto de morava 16 segundos para
registrar aquela foto
esse cara trabalhava dentro da kodak ele
quando ele apresentou para acordar que a
kodak falou isso é besteira vai demorar
15 anos prata e quando surgiu fez
anticorrupção acordar que acabou
praticamente falhando no mesmo ano que o
instagram lançou e foi vendido por um
milhão de dólares facebook 13
funcionários inclusive um brasileiro foi
um dos criadores do dc desse produto
hoje temos uma câmera que é mil vezes
tem uma tia resolução mil vezes mais
leve
mil vezes mais barata ou seja é um
bilhão de vezes melhor do que a câmera e
vetada em 76 ou seja eu tinha eu tinha
cinco anos de idade seja 10 megapixels
qual é um grama e 10 dólares seja um
bilhão de vezes e essa tecnologia que
não está boa
isso aqui é um medidor de posição ainda
se inercial você acelerômetro giroscópio
estava milhões de dólares
pesava 25 quilos 1960 hoje um
acelerômetro e um giroscópio cabe no
nosso celular custam menos de 1 dólar
qual o futuro disso máquinas moleculares
incorporadas no nosso corpo tem dentro
de nós
esse aqui foi o primeiro gps comercial
1981 pesava 25 quilos custou 120 mil
dólares
hoje cabe na ponta do meu dedo custa
menos de 5 dólares e essa curva que
vocês observam aqui a lei de amor que o
cara que um dos fundadores da intel ele
dizer que a cada 18 24 meses você dobra
a capacidade de um processador mantendo
o mesmo preço seja mil dólares significa
que eu tenho um computador que é uma
velocidade resolve mais informações
em dois anos ele está fazendo pela
metade do tempo e mais dois anos e está
fazendo por um quarto tempo isso vai
reduzindo o tempo de velocidade e depois
ele pegou foi observar o passado e
observou a mesma coisa
mesmo com a guerra mesmo com as guerras
conflitos cartão perfurado riley tubo a
vácuo transistores circuito integrado
hoje temos um computador de mil dólares
que tem a capacidade de processamento de
um cérebro de um rato em 2023 teremos um
computador de mil dólares com a
capacidade de processamento do cérebro
humano em 2050 teremos um computador com
a capacidade de processamento de toda a
humanidade de 8 bilhões de pessoas o que
isso representa para nós então que eu
vou mostrar pra vocês aqui quais são as
quatro características básicas dessas
tecnologias exponenciar do crescimento
exponencial
a primeira delas é a digitalização
quando transforma alguma coisa física em
dados indigestos e zeros e uns
ela automaticamente entra naquela lei
disponibilidade ela
naquela curva e quando entra naquela
curva ela entramos nos passos
exponenciais lembra o im 248 vai subindo
o segundo passo segundo t das
tecnologias exponenciais é a
desmaterialização antigamente você andar
eu sairia na rua assim carregando um
câmera um sons e três músicas 20 anos
depois eu carrego tudo isso no seu lar
se desmaterializou pelo tamanho mínimo
de uma câmera que vocês viram naquela
outra imagem e as aplicações software o
terceiro dedo das tecnologias
exponenciais eads monetização se eu
tinha antes uma câmera que tinha um
filme e eu já estava uma grana não
revelava aquilo perdia hoje eu tenho um
zilhão de fotos pra escolher agora tem
um problema tem 18 fotos diferentes eu
não sei mais qual eu vou usar
então tá diz monetizando o perdi
monetária está democratizando a frota de
táxis
o skype diz monetizando as ligações
físicas todo mundo hoje faz skype quando
você paga para fazer o skype 0
praticamente zero o custo é marginal
o rb nib é a maior cadeia de hotéis do
mundo sem ter um único quarto usando
tecnologias exponenciais qual é o último
de dessa história das tecnologias
exponenciais se eu digitalizei diz
desmaterializa diz monetize ei é a coisa
mais bonita da tecnologia democratização
ela fica acessível hoje eu compro um
telefone na índia smartphone estou
falando de joão não compra o smartphone
por seis dólares com o android rodando
nele pra vocês terem uma idéia a
escassez a economia é baseada na
escassez
quando eu pego é a escassez é contextual
ela não é uma coisa feia contextual é um
problema de acesso se eu tenho uma
laranjeira enorme cheio de laranja tem
uma laranja
meu alcance mas depois ela vai acabar
vou só bater os laranjas mas com a peça
de tecnologia que você vai inventar para
ter acesso às laranjas que estão no alto
da escada a indicada torna aquilo queres
de caçu em abundante e aí têm acesso à
escada dá o acesso ao a laranja vocês
terem uma idéia hoje o laboratório na
silicon valle já está fazendo um
diamante perfeito 5 dólares o quilate
você precisar de um quiser dar um
diamante para minha esposa 18 quilates
eu vou gastar 90 dólares
qual é a ruptura que vai acontecer com
as minas de exploração na áfrica o uso
trabalho escravo abusivo a indústria que
gira em torno de amante contrabando que
erra você imagina o que vai acontecer
com essa ruptura e seu laboratório
obviamente se um laboratório em silicon
valley mas pode ser um laboratório aqui
à volta redonda se vocês decidirem se
pode colocar numa chaminé da fábrica um
captador de carbono que vai acumular
aquilo vai gerar uma pressão galera de
engenharia
o problema hoje eu vi no palco a minha
visão eu vi um monte de oportunidades de
negócio de você ficar milionário que
várias mas várias aqui te contar os dois
dedos nos dez dias das duas mãos
então essas tecnologias exponenciais são
redes de computadores sensores
inteligência artificial robótica
impressão e manufatura digital biologia
sintética ciências de novos materiais
que vão gerar consequências convergentes
inesperadas pra contar e ilustrar um
caso muito legal sobre isso eu quero
kasparov quando ele perdeu a partida por
exemplo aquele computador que aconteceu
kasparov depois daquilo acabou história
ele morreu
virou professor foi plantar bananas
batatas num deles saiu irritado daquela
pt ter perdido aquele jogo
sou um cara que eu vou fazer o
computador perfeito que pegou todas as
jogadas e permite que eu posso escolher
então ele resolveu criar um negócio
chamado free style jazz o seu xadrez
estilo livre ele criou o fc do xadrez
vou usar diversas técnicas agora vamos
fazer um campeonato em que temos
jogadores que podem só tocar o hit aí
pode tocar play kid tá rolando você
diminuir os tempos de jogo você pode
jogar em times e eles são chamados de
centaurus esse jogador já de si um
formato cental eles vão trocando de
posição aqui tal kasparov e que tal
magnus carlsen magnus carlsen tem 22
anos é o maior jogador de xadrez do
planeta ea inteligência que mais se
aproxima da inteligência artificial e
eles vão jogando em jogada rápida banda
free não pode ter a estratégia de
quebrar é uma fazer uma jogada fake é
falsa e seguir eu quero que as para a
vida jogando e ele criou essa capacidade
em 2014 para vocês terem idéia as macro
e jogam com inteligência utilizando
computadores auxiliando eles como se
fosse como se fossemos nós dirigindo no
carro com gps a não aqui o gps vai
orientando cheguei do rio de janeiro
volta redonda
botei no navegador ele me entregou no
lugar eu queria sem perguntar se nunca
ter vindo aqui mas o qual eu poderia ter
chegado determinado manda dizer que não
vou por esse caminho vou por esse
caminho o eu posso te ligar o gps não
preciso de gps eu vou tomar decisão eles
fizeram a mesma coisa
em 2014 as máquinas de inteligência
artificial garoto 42 partidas e os
centauros ganhar os 53 partidas
o que isso quer dizer que a inteligência
artificial vai fazer uma ruptura dos
nossos empregos até meu próprio emprego
está ameaçado mas o que vai acontecer a
inteligência artificial pode ser usada a
meu favor
se isso é usado num jogo
o o que imagina o que é inteligência
artificial para os médicos psiquiatras
para os contabilistas proíbe ólogos dos
advogados vai aumentar as nossas
capacidades levando a singularidade e
seu magnus carlsen 22 anos ele tem
vídeos no youtube ele joga dez partidas
com contra dez jogadores de costas
olhando as memoriza as posições
é incrível o garoto e agora nós temos
tecnologias exponenciar vocês estão
tensos
temos aqui os 16 objetivos do milênio om
problemas reais pobreza miséria
igualdade de gênero vimos isso ao longo
de todo dia comunidades sustentáveis
vida debaixo do mar vida na terra
combate às alterações climáticas
eu digo a vocês com toda clareza e
tranquilidade do mundo enquanto houver
problemas de nós não ficaremos
desempregados com toda tranquilidade em
2022 teremos três bilhões de pessoas
conectadas na internet existem três
bilhões de pessoas que estão fora da
internet hoje vozes que nunca ouvimos
soluções que jamais imaginamos essa
galera vai entrar com tudo
então eu quero deixar a mensagem muito
clara pra vocês aqui nesse ambiente
olhando nos olhos de vocês vocês podem
olhar as tecnologias e os policiais e dá
um passo para trás
isso não vai acontecer comigo a minha
empresa não vai sofrer uma ruptura ou eu
posso dar um passo para frente e assumir
que as tecnologias disponíveis existem
aqui que existem problemas bizarros para
ser resolvidos no mundo
o dinheiro vai surgir eu digo isso com
muita tranquilidade muita clareza tem
muito dinheiro em jogo possível para ser
investido usem os propósitos massivos
trans transformadores transforma a vida
das pessoas
não vamos sair daqui desse teatro e
vamos ver a volta redonda que tá ali ela
não vai se modificar
mas vocês estão saindo daqui modificadas
vocês estão saindo eu quero ver esse
brilho no olhar de você está na mão de
vocês uma ideia uma tecnologia
exponencial ou várias tecnologias
policiais em um propósito massivo
transformador e vocês vão mudar a vida
de vocês como ted mudou a nossa vida o
texas assim goulart e ouro
diversas outras organizações estão ao
alcance das nossas mãos é possível então
eu desejo a vocês boa sorte e vamos
trabalhar juntos
obrigado
[Aplausos]